i had no experience in coding like the
last experience i had in coding was like
junior year of high school and it was
just background color changes the one
thing i knew with code was that the
color white was fff
that's all i got hello everybody my name
is nyan i'm the black female engineer i
provide content for new and aspiring
software engineers and today i am going
over this grand
career switch i made for me it was great
because it really kind of was at you
know day and night just one day i was in
finance and the next day i was not i
went from having a finance offer for
about i believe it was 45 000 to
accepting an offer of over 120
dollars worth when it came to salary and
bonuses and stock and so yeah let me get
into that so all this happened a year
ago in the spring of 2020
and so i'm pretty sure that
phrase itself brings on a lot of
feelings for many people and so yes for
me it was in the spring of 2020 and i
was on my way to my like first class of
the day i was a college student i was
majoring in finance and accounting i was
a senior in college and i was just six
weeks away from graduating with my
degree i get along with 30 000 other
students an email saying hey y'all
after y'all go home today
we'll never see you again and it was
like
huh like what
what just happened all just suddenly
the world
stopped
my world stopped and i suddenly as we
most of us i think felt had all of this
time it was a like a pause it was three
months after new year's all the goals
you had planned and everything now you
had the time to do it you could lose
that weight you could learn the skill x
y and z the time is yours and so
it took me a couple days to do that i
remember actually having back pain from
the amount of time i spent laying in bed
i literally just laid in bed for days
until one day i was like okay girl like
we gotta
do something that we can't lay in bed
for in my mind like two more weeks and
so i'm like okay let's learn something
new i remember posting this instagram
that was like i may not be losing weight
but i'm learning something new and it
was actually a boomerang of me on free
code camp and just learning the basics
of html and css now my decision to learn
to code had nothing to do with a career
switch at all it was just
i think many of us can vouch for the
fact that coding is something that
people just say to learn just like how
people say oh you should put time in for
traveling and things like that that's
just a thing people say coding
is one of those things and so now i had
all this time i was like okay you know
what people keep saying this is a great
thing to learn like let me try it out i
have all this time so let's see so yes i
started looking up just resources to
learn to code i'm not a book reader when
it comes to learning new skills i prefer
hands-on action and so yeah i looked up
the best way to do that with learning to
code as a complete complete beginner i
had no experience in coding like the
last experience i had in coding was like
junior year of high school and it was
just colored background color changes
the one thing i knew with code was that
the color white was
fff f that's all i got and so yes look
up how to learn to code and free code
camp came up and i really liked their
platform it was a very easy to use
platform you didn't need to download
anything you didn't need to go on vs
code you didn't need to do any of the
additional things coding can entail and
so i really really loved it and i was
hooked i was so hooked within just a few
hours that that day in about three to
four days thereafter i stayed up till 3
a.m learning html and css so much so
that after about one to two hours of
learning on free code camp i would go
myself around and end up downloading vs
code and just my own tools so that i
could test my own learning and create
these static web pages nothing fancy at
all like it was not good even thinking
about what projects i made now i'm so
proud of them then and i should have
been because you know i had no
experience but looking at it now i'm
like wow
oh
yeah not a sight for sore eyes but yes i
was just so hooked on it so after about
a week of that i started to really panic
because i was like oh my gosh
i want this i want i want to do this all
the time and be paid a nice chunk of
change for it and so i started to panic
because if you remember i but at the
start of the story was just six weeks
away from graduating now i'm about five
to four weeks away from
graduating and i don't have a job and
now i'm not gonna get a job because the
world is shut down so now i'm not even
like get a job and all of this and so i
was fortunate enough to get an interview
for this one job as a credit analyst and
you know it's not really anything to
make your heart pound with excitement
but i was like okay it's a job like
let's see how it goes and so i go
through the whole interview process
while simultaneously trying to learn
what i can do about this whole situation
i'm in now now about a week and a half
has passed since the start of the story
and so around that time cnbc's
make it
put out a video i'm pretty sure we all
know it i don't even have to say it of
the amazing bukola and her story of how
she became a software engineer
without a degree and what's funny is
that's not i wasn't even the tagline i
was just watching it because it was like
wow 210 000 and it's a black woman i
don't think i like cnbc's making it
especially because of the finance part
of it because i was a finance major i
don't recall ever seeing a black
woman not part of a couple episode who
made that much
ever in one of their episodes at the
time i it may have been there but i
didn't see it and so i was so quick to
click on this episode and watch it just
be like wow like look at her
and then she starts talking
and she's talking about how she's a
software engineer and so that was for me
a sign in itself then she's talking
about how she didn't get a degree in it
and so i was like hold up hold the
up but at some point during the video
she talks about coding bootcamps now she
didn't go to a coding bootcamp but i had
never even heard the term at all i
didn't know what she was really talking
about until she explained it further and
so i first tried to see the you know
free opportunities there were to learn
to code the ones she talked about but
geographically it was limited and so i
did look more into coding boot camps and
i stumbled upon flatiron school at the
time the top coding bootcamps i was
looking at were flat art school and
general assembly because when i looked
up top coding boot camps those were the
ones that popped up i'm not saying
they're the top i'm just saying those
are the ones that popped up like
and so google told me that these were
the best i was like okay bet because i'm
gonna need it because i have no
experience so i'm gonna need a top tier
program and so yes start the whole
interview process and application
process with flat iron school i ended up
leaning more towards them i can't
remember why i leaned more towards
finance school versus general assembly
because i actually didn't even have an
interview with general assembly i didn't
even apply
to that point i think it's that by the
time general assembly reached back to me
i was already pretty deep into flatiron
and keep in mind i'm trying to graduate
i am also interviewing for another job
in a different field and so i was just
tired and so i was like you know let me
just put all my focus into flat iron
school so i go through the application
process and i get in i have a link above
explaining the application and interview
process but yeah i get accepted i
applied for an isa in the income share
agreement because
coding boot camps are expensive
they are
expensive your girl didn't have 100
bucks to her name never mind 15 000
and so yes i applied for an isa which i
got and then boom it was off to the
races to prepare for boot camp between
the time of my acceptance and the first
day of school it was about a month in
between which is actually shorter than
this advice because they really want you
to prepare
beforehand they give you a lot of
pre-work and homework and so you really
want to make sure you're not lagging
behind because now you're behind before
you even start
so that's not good at that time i also
found out that i got the job as a credit
analyst they offered me 45 000 and for
me i was like no i'm okay not really
because of the money but because the
money didn't help but
but because over the years i had
realized that finance as a career just
wasn't for me i have a video above
explaining that as well but yeah finance
as a job just wasn't for me and so now
add a
lower than average salary on top of it
yes it's covered and everything but i'm
just saying my mentality like yeah
i don't even like it and the pay isn't
good so it's like so why am i why would
i go why why am i here and so yes so i
decided to decline the offer so i just
go full force in with flatiron which is
15 weeks long so just about four months
and i
you could not reach me in that time i
was full head down mode like you could
not touch me at all do not talk to me do
not know friends who i don't know them
and so that was me during those four
months it sounds awful but yo i was
serious about this fifteen thousand
dollars is a lot of money i was not
about to be in the hook for that and
also not have a job and so yes did a lot
of just
school work by the halfway point i
started applying to jobs this is not
what anyone else really did and it's not
really advised but i was like advisal
schmeizel like no we need a job now and
so i started applying to jobs early
really trying to network and reach out
to people on linkedin and do all of
these different things to increase my
odds of getting that job and it all paid
off because the day of my graduation i
got my first job offer which was insane
so so insane to say that i'm graduating
with a job offer now i didn't choose
that job i didn't choose it but it was
just so nice to know that i had
something and so i didn't choose that
job right off the bat i decided to let
it sit for a little bit while i finished
the interview processes of a couple of
other companies and by the end of that
month which was october so i graduated
october
2nd and by the end of october october
29th i received my job offer for the job
i have now i worked at dreamworks
animations as a developer and it was
weird because they actually hired me a
year out because i was a very new
graduate and with graduate and
undergraduate hiring a lot of times they
do their hiring a year out and so i
actually got this job but then had about
nine months to kind of just chill
while i
waited for the job to start actually
just started my job like six weeks ago
and so yeah i was just chilling but i
was not about to let my coding skills go
to waste because coding is not like
riding a bike at all you can't leave and
come back and all's good like no no do
not do that please and so i decided to
seek out opportunities that would
involve temporary work but i could still
code and develop and make sure i'm
really advancing my skill sets so that i
can even be even more prepared once i
start working here and so i started
working in the commerce cloud
development sphere i had no idea what
congress thought development was to to
be honest if you wanted me to talk about
it i probably would
you you could hear it i probably would
stutter quite a bit um talking about it
but it was a huge huge amazing learning
opportunity and i loved it i loved my
team i loved the projects i've got to
work on and it was phenomenal so here i
am now a year later after declining this
other job in my major declining it and
see getting almost a full 100 000
raise yeah it's almost almost a hundred
thousand when we look at the entire
offer package yeah a solid almost
hundred thousand dollars more and i am
just so happy and proud of all that i
did to get here however it is hard it's
it's not a walk in the park don't think
that oh i just went to boot camp and
here i am like no it's a lot there are a
lot of sleepless nights it's it's a lot
and so there were definitely specific
things i did that helped me get here my
entire channel really is devoted to
providing you with those tips on things
that i did things that i didn't do and
whatnot and so if you're in the same
space right now of trying to transition
into this field or boot camp or
self-teaching definitely check out
different videos if you are more along
your process and are like okay well i
have the skills but i can't get a job i
do provide one-on-one consulting to help
you get to that goal of a job
nowadays a resume doesn't cut it a
resume does not cut especially when you
don't have a computer science degree it
sucks especially with this field where
it's been shown time and time again you
don't need that degree to show that you
can do the job but it just makes it
still unfortunately that much harder to
get the job even though you have the
skills and so check out the link in my
bio for more information on that let me
know in the comments below where you are
in your transition into software
engineering are you still thinking about
it are you involved in a boot camp or is
still self-teaching or are you looking
for a job right now and really just
don't understand how to best navigate
that space so let me know below and
thank you so much for watching i'll talk
to you later bye